hi everyone basically we're going to go
through how to build upon playing AI how
many people think they're going to
actually be following along with the
tutorial like from a code point view
like installing all this stuff you know
show of hands so I've never tried this
on Mac but apparently it should be very
easy on Mac tense flow should run with
cpu version just by kind of installing
it on windows so if you're on Windows
the best option you've got is I'd
actually had examples in the-- a no but
piano and tends to flow are very very
close so you can try and install theano
if you're on Windows and if you're on
Linux that will be the easiest version
but you also then need an NVIDIA GPU so
how many people have nvidia gpus on the
laptop should it should have got an
NVIDIA GPU should it should come up so
is anyone installing right now like I'll
give it maybe like two three minutes for
people to kind of install stuff okay i'm
gonna i'm going to start and if people
want to keep trying to install it as i
go i'll try and speak quietly so i don't
distract you all right so this is
building a pong playing AI google
deepmind recently got the world's best
performance learning a variety of Atari
games and in this talk we're basically
just going to go through how they did it
some of the theory behind it and share a
few implementations so the subjects were
going to cover we're going to very very
briefly touch on neural networks we can
go through reinforcement learning
q-learning tensorflow in a bit of depth
and convolutional networks why pong
because it's a classic simple dynamic
game you can train to play it in a
reasonable amount of time and the task
here is to get the computer to learn it
just from watching the image so it has
no access to the coordinates of the
objects ahead of time it does not know
ahead of time what a ball is or what
paddle is it's just got to learn like a
human at some point
the life must learn by just looking at
the thing and working out this is what's
going on why do we care about this it's
fun it's challenging we can develop
generalized learning algorithms that
could apply to many other fields and it
will allow us to build our future robot
overlords who will one day inherit the
earth from us resources we've already
talked about resources a bit the github
here has all the kind of internal
resources for this so there are a
collection of examples of the different
bit so we're going to cover in the talk
Linux is not a requirement because you
can do this on Mac and can do some
windows but then you're going to be
limited to theano and hopefully at least
some of you can follow along but if not
you can always kind of like complete the
set up afterwards and this will be on
YouTube and stuff pygame is a popular
Python games framework there's thousands
of free open source games and all
written in Python and so that means it's
quite nice if we're writing our learning
agent in pipes and we can just move into
our game and we don't need to muck
around with the Torah code or anything
pygame player is just a little project
that me and another person have worked
on that allows running a pie game with
zero touch so for a lot of examples
remove enforcement on you see they
actually have to hack the game code to
change it to return a screen buffer and
stuff like that pi game player just it
basically intercepts the screen buffer
as it's coming in and then intercepts
the key presses so it just handles all
the kind of framework aspects for you oh
and it allows you to run the game a
fixed frame rate you can say Ryan at ten
frames per second or 20 frames per
second it'll just always be running at
that speed no matter how long you take
to kind of compute so normal pong is 640
by 480 so for the purposes of this I
built a mini pong if I just go to
actually let me go so mini pong is just
a very small version of pong because
it's it'll be 40 by 40 when I actually
run it and this means that you don't do
down sampling of the screen to feed it
into the agent and then to make it even
simpler I've developed half pong
tommasini even pong can be hard and a
half pong there's only a single bar so
all it has to do is hit the hit the ball
and then it gets points just every time
it hits the opposite wall and hopefully
this might be able to train in like the
length of time that this takes if you
kind of started training it now if any
wants to do that we could try that
otherwise you can do after and let me
just really quickly show half pong
running that's the big version so that's
that's half pong and then if I change
the screen resolution
nevermind okay so the first example for
this we're going to show is just random
pong and random pong there's the example
here and that way we're just going to
randomly move about the screen hitting
Keys within the range of normal hongki's
and that's going to give us a baseline
for how long how well the agent does so
if I go to the first example here's
random Hong and it's just completely
randomly moving and it will occasionally
hit the ball hopefully and get a few
points but this is pretty bad and
obviously showing no real intelligence
here's how you would implement it it's
pretty simple so you just inherit from
the PI game player base class and in the
start method we just set it to run we
pass in the screen dimensions and that
will handle all the other stuff for you
and then here the get keys press method
is called every time the screen is
refreshed and then you can set in what
keys you want to be pressed the next
time ask for keys and then the one thing
we need to supply with the game is we
need to supply a feedback function
because it's bit mean asking it to learn
a game just from looking at it also
needs some kind of feedback to say when
we scored a point or when we lost a
point just so it has something to learn
off because otherwise what is success
how good is random half pong it's not
very good it scores naught point naught
like negative naught point naught 3 so
it's significantly less than fifty
percent so now we'll go through a few
examples of trying to improve it so
first let's try using neural networks
who here kind of knows a bit about
neural networks we have reasonably as
that looks like most people so I'll
pretty much skip this except say if you
don't know about neural networks for the
purpose of this it's just like a thing
that is able to approximate complex
functions
so here's the invitation for an MLP a
multi-layer perceptron half pong we're
going to set the number of frames per
second to six which is yet the cursor
will have this which is going to create
our network and it's going to give us
back an input layer and output layer the
input layer is what we're going to feed
the screen buffer into and the output
layer is what we're going to get
basically a score for each potential
action we could take in pong the actions
are we could hit the up key we could hit
the down key or we could do nothing and
the neural network is going to try and
assign relative values to each of those
and we're going to select the highest
value action it gives us and that will
be the action we take who's used
tensorflow before we have a few people
who's used the I know before very few
more oh so I don't cover this in too
much depth but basically tensorflow
under the hood is a computational graph
so we're going to give it a set of
variables and operations it's going to
perform and then it'll take those
variables and put them through the
operations and it will come out with an
output but basically we set up this
graph ahead of time and then it'll
basically compile everything down and
put it on the GPU if you've got one or
the cpu and allow us to run things like
ridiculously faster than they would if
if they will run through another
mechanism this is just creating a very
simple three layer neural network with
real ooh activation functions so we're
going to give it a set of variables for
the first Slayer weights and biases and
the second leg weights and the biases
we're going to activate it we're going
to do a matrix multiplication between
the input layer and the weights in the
first layer and then the weights in the
second layer and then we going to get an
output double that up cool and then here
is the so in random pong we were just
randomly selecting a move here what
instead we're going to do
we're going to take the binary image
we're going to just stomp lit down so
it's rather than being RGB it's just a
zero or one for like active on that
actor for every screen pixel we're going
to feed that in to the agent and we're
going to take the max action and we're
going to return action key to index and
now to do something really really stupid
here is that song set up with a
multi-layer perceptron and it got lucky
there but basically this is awful now
because we've not actually done any
training this is just like a random
being fed random numbers and failing as
you can see so how does it how does it
do awful we need to train it but what is
a loss function for the game pong does
everyone know about loss functions have
no no in those well as functions so in
neural networks there's three types of
learning there's supervised unsupervised
and reinforcement learning supervised
learning is we have labels for data and
say we have a collection of images of
handwritten digits likely min set data
set and we have labels for which
handwritten digit each of these images
corresponds to when we put the the
pixels through our neural network is
going to give us an output for which
which which which label it thinks
applies to each image and the loss
function is the difference between what
the neural network thought the image was
and what the image actually was and then
we can use the loss function to retrain
the network and use what's called
stochastic gradient descent to kind of
push the various about the various
errors that it got through back through
the network and retrain to eventually
get the correct values but something
like a lost function doesn't work in
this context because it's going to get
periodic feedback from like the ball
being scored against it or it conceding
but that there's not that that's not a
lost function we don't know what the
correct action would have been it
just some noise of the moment so in
reinforcement learning which is the kind
of field we're going to need for this
agents run with an environment they take
actions they receive feedback they aim
to maximize good feedback and minimize
good bad feedback and compute games
being a great way to kind of train
reinforcement learning agents the kind
of most or a very common approach with
reinforcement learning is genetic
algorithms which have been incredibly
successful but the kind of the thing
that's a bit kind of rubbish about
genetic algorithms is humans do not
learn through genetic algorithms you
know we were not born with the genes to
play pong we've worn with the genes to
learn pong so we want we want algorithms
that can actually learn in the same way
that a human might learn or able to
learn these kind of new things not just
randomly look through possibilities and
find things that happen to do well so
this is where we come into q-learning
which is the approach we're going to use
for making this work give in a state and
a set of possible actions the Q function
will try and determine the best action
to take to maximize our reward any
action we take will put in a new state
that has another set of possible actions
our best action now depends on our best
action will be in the next state and
then the next state from then on for
example here is a bunny and he's going
to be dropped into this maze here in
state 5 here if I go down to state 5
there's a carrot which will be
equivalent to 100 reward and the Q
function is going to try and learn which
action is the best to take to
continually get to the carrot here's
after optimization but i just wanted to
jump through to the Q function so here's
what it actually looks like our
corresponds to the reward in the state
we immediately moved to after the action
and this is a discount factor and this
is the maximum of the Q function given
the state we moved into in the action
and so you say we want to go sorry
dynamic program would fall more under
genetic algorithms this is all like the
code is all written ahead of time it's
just we're going to use this to retrain
the weights for like the particular
values of different computations we're
doing so that's that's what the
algorithm looks like and then to kind of
give an example of that with this maze
which also I'd stole this from someone
else's website just to attribute this in
state 5 that's the goal states obviously
the reward for being in state 5 is 100
that corresponds to this little bit here
if you're in state for also the reward
from state 5 is 100 if you're in state 0
well you can move to state for and then
the next turn you can take the maximum
possible action in state for and that's
100 and then we're going to have our
discount factor abnorm out in this case
so it would be the Q function for moving
from 0 to 4 is 80 and a good thing about
the Q function being set up like this is
that moving directly from four to five
is more valuable because even though you
can get 25 from taking the long way
around the discount factor means it's
not as desirable because we want reward
now we don't want reward at some time
the future and after we've optimized our
Q function our bunny will have lots of
carrots that's great the way it's
normally computed is kind of iteratively
so we start with a very bad Q function
we then go through all the possible
states and update the Q function given
the information we get from like what
actions we take in each state then we
then apply the Q function we then
learned which will be this bit to better
estimate the Q value of everything in
the next frame and we will increment
everything by us a earning rate so
eventually over time the Q function
should learn kind of very accurate kind
of distributions of a state space so
arbitrarily it was some number less than
1 because it we want the future to be
less good and more than 0 because we
want the future to have some impact it
falls under piper parameter tuning so
you know some random number so I'm going
to show an example of this with the
world's simplest game so in the world's
simplest game we simply have a kind of a
one dimensional map you're going to get
a reward for getting into the fourth
state and all the other states you're
going to get nothing for and the agent
will be placed in one state and it can
either move forward or backward and we
as humans can pretty accurately solve
this maze I think we all know you want
to you want to move to the rewards back
so and so we've got an implementation of
this intends to flow has anyone actually
gotten tensorflow kind of setup on their
laptops has anyone got theano set up on
their laptops okay we've got a few so
the amazingly ferretti has also written
a theano implementation of this so if
you want to look at that that would be
great here's the tensorflow one the
theater one is is just just hear some
before and here's the implementation
we're going to create our little kind of
mini maze there are two actions you can
either move forward or you can move
backward this has a not modify the
future discount right will create some
placeholder values and these are what
we're going to feed in the state that we
are currently in and also we're going to
get out from these target we're going to
use these targets to as the loss
function when we actually train the
thing
can we turn the lights off on the screen
is it like glare yeah no problem all
right so we're going to set up our
really minigame the this is just going
to like trainer a linear Q function so
it's just a direct mapping from the
input to the hidden whites and it will
just be like there is some number for
each each value intense flow you have to
initialize variables we're going to run
through and iterate through this a bunch
of times and each time we're going to
print out the value that this determines
each state has so let's just see what
that looks like and as we can see on the
first iteration the reward for the the
gold square is 1 point 0 that's what the
actual reward is and then we already
have a slight value from our Q function
which is the future discounted value of
getting to the reward square and the
same for the square on the other side
and then over time it's gradually
improving this estimate until eventually
we have what should be a nice
distribution of the value of being in
each square in our kind of mini maze and
that can be used just you always select
the action that takes you to the highest
value square but we can try we can try
some other values for that so that was
that was a very simple maze we've got to
make make this square really bad so the
agent will try and avoid that and so now
at the end I mean still some roared for
going through the negative square but
it's it's now pretty bad so we don't to
be in the negative square
so that is that has anyone like read
about the Enron scandal I'm going to go
for a really really tortured metaphor
here so we want to apply q-learning to
pong and I think like a good metaphor
for like trying to get these kind of out
like we want to make the game of pong
look like a maze with States to our
queue learning algorithm and so in Enron
the way in which the accounting
department would make all their money is
there are rules about how you can book
something as profit or loss and so what
they would do is they would take
something that was clearly a loss and
they would make it look like something
that could be profit so they would book
it in a certain way they would file it
through certain offshore company they
would follow it back to another company
so that is a metaphor for what we're
about to do here we're going to try and
make pong look like that silly little
one-dimensional maze game so did that
metaphor make this easier or harder to
understand I really like that metaphor
but I wonder if it's awful so in pong
the normal screen size is 640 480 pixels
that's going to be way too big that's
like a huge state space it that
immediately is 2 to the power of 0 2 to
the power of some massive number of
different states and also pawns a
dynamic game so just knowing what the
current screen looks like doesn't really
allow us to tell what's going on in pong
because the velocity of the ball changes
so we want to get a few frames into our
state slipspace so it can learn you know
velocity if we were to choose say for
then the number is still too too big so
we're going to use neural networks to
try and reduce this state space into
something more manageable so that our
cooling algum can learn this so now we
have the NLM lpq learning half pong
player and as well as q-learning we will
need experience replay so we don't just
want to learn of what the current screen
looks like because that would take ages
we want to basically store all the
states we go through in memory as
memories and
and when we're actually learning we can
do mini batch sampling off of that does
everyone know many does anyone know mini
batch sampling ryland training off a
single example we're going to train off
a batch of examples and that will just
learn quicker so we're going to collect
the states that's experienced we're then
going to sample from them and then learn
off that which is replay so this is an
example of we take our binary images we
do something special with the first
frame and then for subsequent frames
we're just going to append our new image
to like a big array with all the
previous images in it and then store
that as an observation training so this
is basically exactly the same algorithm
as for the kind of silly little one day
example but now we have these huge huge
raise that represent the whole screen
and we'll train off those oh and the one
the one difference is in pong there is a
terminal state so if the ball hits the
far wall the game is going to reset
you're going to go back to the normal
position so there's not much point
predicting what your Lord will be after
the reset state you know the reset is
just the end of reward and then you
start a new state and that's training
and the only other thing we have to do
is at first our Q function will be
really really really really really bad
because it's just going to be started
with some random initialized ways so we
want to start with taking completely
random actions and over time hopefully
as our Q function improves will
substitute more and more random actions
for like chosen actions from the network
and eventually we'll just be running
chosen actions and that should give at
that point that should be a good
distribution of things to learn again
learn off so how does it do let's see a
trained network running this so there is
mini half pomp and then let's let's take
a closer look
so you'll see this is doing better than
random but not significantly better than
random so that was awful but there's
movements like that that are clearly not
random movements it's it's going for the
ball it's learned some kind of pattern
out of this and that was pretty good as
well but there's a lot of work to be
done so that yeah you can see the score
down at the bottom there it's scoring
like very slightly positive so way above
random but still not that great so why
is that probably not doing that well the
reason that's probably not doing well is
because there's no linear mapping from a
from the screen of pong to to the actual
actions that we take what we actually
care about are the kind of relative
positions of things it doesn't matter if
the ball is in the top five for the
screen on the bottom half what matters
is where the ball is relative to our to
our bar and linear or shall I mappings
will not be able to tell us this they're
just going to be going off the kind of
absolute position of activations in the
network and so like like everyone has
heard the term deep learning kind of
passed around everywhere that's a fair
assumption one of the things with deep
learning is its kind of automatically
allowing us to learn features but also
it's allowing us to learn invariant
representations so the idea is the more
layers we have will start to get two
layers where they're not just learning
individual activations but they're
learning things that don't tend to vary
as far as the higher layers of concern
so this will allow us to learn things
like the position of the ball relative
to the bar is a factor as opposed to
just the absolute position of a thing
and the other point of this is
convolutional nets and a bit more depth
that's the other thing we left the other
thing we're going to be using here is
the kind of the first few layers of our
network the thing convolutional networks
is or the insight as to why
convolutional networks are good is we as
humans know that if we take the pixel in
the
the top of this you the things that give
the meaning of you to that pixel are
very unlikely to be pixels over here or
pixels over here or pixels over here
when we're talking about like what the
meaning of something in an image is what
we really only care about are things
really really close to it it's very
unlikely that something in an image is
actually correlated with something very
far away at kind of that lower level so
a convolutional net basically we'll
start off by detecting features just in
a very small space of the image and it
will like a sliding window kind of move
across the image and compute things that
it can get from just the few pixels
around the kind of central point so
that's what we're going to use here so
here is the implementation of the
convolutional net half pong player very
briefly intensive flow there is a a calm
2d method and we can pass in strides
which is how far we're going to move
across each dimension as we're going
we're going to put this together and
this is hopefully going to be a bit
better at playing pong so how does it do
should we should we run this up and see
let me stop previous one so let's see
and hopefully this will do a bit better
let's zoom in so how's that someone ok
ah that's Nick come on do better do Bell
it there we go so you'll have to believe
me this this isn't looking so great
right now but its scores significantly
better than the than just the kind of
shallow network you can also the check
points for this network that are saved
our kind of available on the github so
you can kind of run it yourself and you
can also try training from scratch to
kind of see that but if you just take my
word for it this is about like thirty
percent above its scoring what is it
like sixty-five percent of points here
which is not too bad so how does it do
it's it's amazing now it's amazing that
wasn't that was amazing right right
right guys
so let me go actually now I can do it
from here let me go back to the code so
we have a convolutional layer we have a
mac spooling layer we have another
convolutional there we have another mac
spooling layer and then we have to just
normal kind of neural network players or
with redirected huh yea yea the deep
mind one uses like another third
convolutional max pooling layer I think
but this is my laptop so you know I had
to make make savings so now it's amazing
and now our future overall the overlords
are pretty close that's that's the next
step the same architecture can be used
on all kinds of other games so this has
been used on break out Cuba seaquest
space invaders cool thank you hope hope
you enjoyed this any questions thank you
yeah so this is using an atom optimizer
I've seen rms prop used as well I think
it also works with grain descent but
like there's so many things you could
try this has worked so I've not messed
around with it until after this you know
just so I don't screw things up any
question
close pixels they're not definitely
correlated but they're much much more
likely to be correlated so you know the
the the the shape of a letter is going
to be dependent on the pixels next to
one of the pixels and thing it's very
unlikely to that there happens to be an
association between like a pixel in one
letter and a pixel like on the far side
of the screen so in some sense what and
this is like there are loads of other
ways of looking at it in some sense what
a convolutional net is doing is just
giving you like a few activations in the
small area that are much more likely to
be connected as opposed to like having
to check every every neuron against
every pixel rather against every other
pixel where you know they're very
unlikely or that kind of almost
shouldn't be connections between the
further away pixels yeah
so they come across so what was that
yeah yeah yeah that is an approach that
could be tried I don't think that would
be cheating I think the main thing is
though we want something that works not
just for pong we want what you know
ideally well actually no you can do
whatever you want yeah they wouldn't be
cheating is probably would be or it
could work quite well I don't know it
would be worth trying any other
questions has anyone actually managed to
like run this well have been talking how
did it do or how's it looking
yeah that but as well yeah yeah it's a
sub-module cuz you successfully did it
kind grab you after this and you help me
like making / make the setup steps
actually work about they'll be great
thank you any other questions Oh
oh yeah open gym looks really really
great I'm definitely going to try
putting a few things into there just to
like see how it is it but also it open
gym is not like a reinforcement learning
library it's a reinforcement learning
like environment library so it doesn't
provide any algorithms it's just like a
really really good space for like trying
out algorithms getting a peer-reviewed
seeing what other people have done it
sounds really great and I'm definitely
going to be playing around with it at
some point any any other questions I've
got like another half hour so it's going
to be really boring from now on unless
someone asks a question or something
what bit did I explain awfully were
there any bits that were just like that
you have no idea what I was talking
about yet so that but what the algorithm
for training okay let me go back to the
the tents flow one first actually you
know what will be even better the Q
function versus the tents fo
implementation okay so that is the kind
of the Q function bit so in this set as
we're going through this kind of
iteration of the thing we're going to
create each state once and this one hot
just in code something is like 0 0 0 1 0
0 and 1 is the state we're actually in
we're then going to get so the minus
action the plus action is just what
would happen if I move forward or
backward through the network then here
so are our kind of output here is
basically the output of a Q function so
we're going to use our network as it's
been trained up to this point just kill
that we can use as it's been trained up
at this point to estimate the Q value of
what it's being given and that step
corresponds to this thing in here so
that's that's that bit of the Q function
we're going to grab that we then once we
have the two actions that it could have
taken in
from its current state we're then going
to take the max of the actions from that
so that that bit is the max we're going
two times that max by the future
discount on the ward which is gamma here
and then we're going to append or add to
that the actual roared received in each
state so zero and all of them except for
one in the reward state and then the
loss function is the difference between
that and what our network thought it was
previously so it'll just you know it
will adjust all the weights to kind of
learn that and then the example in pong
is almost identical except we just have
the concept of a terminal state so if we
get into the terminal state like there's
no there's no future award you're dead
that's was that was that better I was
better cool any other questions any
other bits that were just like they did
not explain at all any other bits that
made no sense yeah
yeah yeah so I I've gotten really into
tensorflow part of why I like tensorflow
actually Soleil might be able to have
some input here she did the theano
implementation tensorflow has the nice
thing that you can just say you can
create an optimizer is it you can create
an optimizer and you say like I just
want to I want to minimize this thing
piano has some of those things but it's
it's kind of just it's harder that
training bit to do in theano you often
have to do more bits by hand piano is
quite a lot faster than tensorflow still
but I just I kind of feel like I
wouldn't bet against tensorflow because
it has google behind it it's got huge
community support so if you I've been
talking to one of the guys at Google who
works on tensorflow and he's been like
the most helpful person in the world
like they are committed to like getting
people involved with this library so
kind of like communities for matters
quite a lot for any library piano but
you don't get the same kind of response
of yours questions on it and just
because it's backed by Google a just I
wouldn't bet against it I mean it's
probably going to become the kind of
pretty defect I standard and deep mind
of switching to it and other people
switching to it so that that we my two
cents yeah
yeah it's a very good question so
deepmind quoted the deep link paper
quotes like numbers in the layers i'm
using fewer in here because I've made
the screen even smaller so I just I just
kind of cut out a layer from there one
it seemed to work this is one of the
frustrations with this stuff is I'm
actually I can show you I've got another
example here which is like a kind of big
proper like full-scale thing and I had
the idea that I would show this today
and I was trying to Train it let me open
another thing I was trying to Train it
like last night and stuff like that and
hoped I could show like a full-size one
but it just it hasn't worked it's it's
like I'll show it now it's awful it
could be awful because because I just
got unlucky and it got into some weird
local minima oh sorry let me switch to
playback mode it could be awful because
I parameters wrong it could be awful
because there's some bug in there it's
it's very hard to know it's kind of at
the moment it's a case of like find
something that works and then don't mess
around with it but I'm sure there will
be better better approaches to this
developed and put in the future or I
really hope so yes this is this is not
not doing great I don't know what's gone
wrong here this is I wasn't going to
show this but I've showed this an
example of it not working so it it
serves that purpose and in fact I'm
going to stop that plane because it
makes me feel sad let's let's go back to
the one that worked that actually works
yeah
so this is 40 x 40 the other one is 640
x 480 but then I've also i'm using cv-22
down Sam plet 280 x 80 I think the
google deepmind paper actually quotes
they down sample it 284 beta for I think
or something huh but that kind of range
well this is I the this way I thought so
but I kind of like so when I went to bed
last night it was looking quite good I
got in the morning and it was awful
maybe more like me I think it might just
got stuck in some kind of local minima
or you know just something has gone
wrong maybe I start from scratch and do
it again it'll be fine just the way too
bad it's hard to tell no but well this
is met yeah well I I thought it's gonna
get better yeah early stopping great
okay yeah tensorflow does a thing of
saving previous checkpoints but it's
like I'd left it overnight so it only
saved like the previous five and even
the earliest one was still a bit crap
but that works yeah yeah
um yeah no I mean because I'm basically
the thing you want is you want like what
yeah what you want is like the best
possible distribution to learn off like
the what playing good pong looks like
the reason start with random is because
you know the computer hasn't learned it
yet if you could actually learn off a
good tire that would probably be even
better but obviously then someone's got
to play pong for like a few days it's
not that funny game wouldnt recommend it
yeah
yeah I've not read of any work like that
as possible as to like the convolutional
layers let me see what I've ended up
with this was kind of like half taken
from the deep mind paper in half like
kind of hacked about so what's that four
versus four oh and also someone also
posted quite a lot of the codes of deep
mine thing that I borrowed heavily from
as well just to attribute these are the
weights for the for the that's that's
what the variables look like for the
second convolutional there that's the
first one so see it's going to go down
from a 40 by 40 screen to an eight by
eight with like thirty two sets of
features 64 in next line I think that's
similar to what deepmind used there may
be better a better options there may be
worse options but I it would take really
really long to try lots of networks and
see which are better unfortunately oh
yeah yeah
um well I think you I think you can
always train at CPU level like it you
know it would be but it well it will
just take ages I depends how long how
long your thing is I had an
implementation this in a previous laptop
which only had a CPU and the difference
in speed like things that were taking me
like days on the previous laptop I could
do in minutes on this thing it was also
an old laptop but you but you know even
if it's an old laptop like you're
getting orders of magnitude improvement
from a GPU you just if you want to be
doing this seriously you're going to
want a GPU at some point or like space
on an Amazon Cloud Servers whatever yeah
so when I first built this I tried it
with two frames and it was doing
terribly so I switched to four then I
realized the problem was some completely
unrelated bug it might be if I try this
with two now it works I just haven't had
time hit it you think bouncing won't
work ah possib no because you know which
way it must have bounced there's only
one option for kind of yeah but it's
unlikely so if we're talking about we're
near a wall and got the two things here
it's like that's the only possibility it
can't have gone all the way to the other
wall and back oh you mean a directly
straight line possibly i think there's
kind of set like this ball can only move
at certain sets of angles it can never
go quite straight but it varies Adam a
four is working and I'm kind of like
until you know like i was doing this
today it seemed really bad luck to start
like mucking around with everything just
before I did this I just have stuck with
things that were working
yeah so I've not tried this myself yet
I've just been mucking around with pong
the google deepmind paper they cite like
20 27 games something like that and they
show that it performs very well like
human level or better for like a
significant number of them so the ones I
mentioned in the slide were ones that I
did really well on to do so breakout
qubit seaquest space invaders and
apparently that is using like exactly
the same algorithm like no changes to
the to the number of layers obviously
you retrain the weights but it's exactly
the same code but it also performs very
badly on a lot of other games so it's
more to be done yeah
yeah yeah without some kind of so what
they use is a common name off the top of
my head but it's called the Atari game
playing framework and they've like
they've already like built in those
little signals just without those
signals like there is no way for the
computer to know what is a good or bad
response we as humans i think we
intuitively know that like you hit stuff
with a ball that's what you do because
we've learned that as babies or
something so we don't need to be told
that but that's yeah
yeah yeah yeah just okay yeah damn
that's that sounds like a good way of
doing it and the other thing the like
Keith Oh Stanley I think kind of whole
thing on novelty search so one of the
ideas is rather than optimizing for like
some variable if you don't have it just
try and optimize the thing to look
forward situations that do not look like
previous situations so I'd love to see
someone try something like that just
just optimizing for exploring they say
so we have another question oh yeah
oh yeah oh you mean like take a portion
of this and put it into something else
yeah I mean there's a whole field called
transfer learning which is about getting
Nets they've been trained on one thing
to work with another thing and so what
to save like that's yeah that's that's a
whole field I'm not sure how much I can
add right now on that it's that people
tried it and there are there are ways in
which you can have some level of success
for things like that cool if no one's
got any more questions I think I'm gonna
sit down because it's just weird I'm
just standing here oh yeah it it
probably would you would need to add
like a new layer somewhere with new
mappings but i would be i think that
would almost certainly work yeah I would
be surprised if it didn't but then you
never really know until you try with
these things because things that look
like they really really really should
work cannot work because it's still an
evolving field oh yeah oh I thought you
put sorry I thought you put your head
you went like that that's all right okay
cool thank you very much everyone I'm
gonna sit down
you